y
más
y no empezar esta charla con una
pregunta a quien de ustedes no se sintió
alguna vez como este hámster que está
acá atrás corriendo a full con 100 mails
para contestar 50 grupos de whatsapp
pasó alguna vez levante la mano el que
al menos una vez se sintió así
yo también
ramiro les contó que yo trabajo en
investigación de mercado y eso significa
que le pregunto a los consumidores cómo
se quieren sentir como no que quieren
comprar que no y una cosa que no quieren
sentirse es así pero la verdad es que
cuando la gente se siente así alucina y
empieza a fantasear con escaparse
entonces dice sabes que jimena largo
todo y me voy al sur me compro una
cuchara de madera de este tamaño me voy
a hacer mermelada casera y que me vengan
a buscar
y si no me dice en el sur paisaje
tropical sabes que jimena me voy a
brasil a vender choclos y que ahí sí que
me traten de agarrar con los grupos de
whatsapp les pasó alguna vez todos
conocemos a alguien que se fue a hacer
mermelada y la onda jingles no cerró del
todo no el querer escaparse del lugar
falla entonces nos queremos escapar en
el tiempo y empezamos a alucinar y
decimos bueno sabes que sabes cuando
estaban tranquilos y no estaban a full
con la tecnología la edad media en la
edad media así ahí sí que estaban
tranquilos las mujeres se las pasaban
bordando los hombres se las pasaban
cosechando y ahí no había el grupo la
mamá de whatsapp el grupo del colegio
100 mails sin contestar pero saben que
la verdad es que la edad media había un
montón de tecnología de hecho saben cuál
era una de las favoritas de la media la
catapulta fue para que la usaban para
captar voltearse entre ellos por la
lucha del territorio así que la onda del
momento era más parecida a game of
thrones que a una playa
idílica y relajada entonces ya sé ya sé
me voy a ir mucho más atrás no me voy a
la de media me voy ir a la época de los
romanos por ejemplo la antigüedad y ahí
sí que seguro estaban todos tiraditos de
costado comiendo visitas y no estaban
subiendo su banquete a instagram y no
estaban todos obsesionados con ese tema
pero saben que los romanos tenían un
montón de tecnología tenían acueductos
con los que construían y unían grandes
ciudades y sobre todo tenían carreteras
que de hecho siguen vigentes hasta hoy
en día y creo como una gran internet
física porque conectaban información y
conectaban a la gente y la verdad es que
sí hubo una época en el mundo donde un
like o un dislike fue algo groso fue con
los romanos sobre todo si te lo daba el
emperador y sobre todo si vas un
gladiador podría hacer la diferencia
entre la vida y la muerte pero
acompáñenme en el viaje en el tiempo y
vayámonos más atrás todavía al máximo
atrás que podamos vayámonos al
paleolítico en las cavernas que puede
fallar que podría estar mal nada no hay
seguro que sí que no tenían tecnología
pero saben que si tenían y tenían la
tecnología más importante todas tenían
el fuego y saben para qué sirvió el
fuego para hacernos humanos es lo que
nos dio la gran diferencia entre otras
especies y nosotros y las herramientas
de piedra y no se la pasaban todo el día
pintando bisontes como vemos acá y
también otra cosa más me imagino por
supuesto que no estuve ahí que no haber
sido nada relajado estar en una cueva
tratando de evitar que te coman los
depredadores que están afuera
entonces cuando ir a hacer mermelada no
no funciona cuando ir más en el tiempo
no funciona cuando ya no nos queda otra
que meternos dentro de la caverna para
ver si ahí estaban más tranquilos y aún
así no funciona nos vamos totalmente
para adelante en el tiempo ahí sí que la
tecnología nos va a salvar no estamos de
acuerdo que nos va a salvar vamos a
vivir muchos más años vamos a tener un
montón de cosas positivas para la salud
gracias a la tecnología y sobre todo las
tecnologías y los robots nos van a
evitar hacer trabajos aburridos y hasta
un poco más nos van a venir a cebar mate
no debería pasar que puede salir mal
pero sin embargo al poco de andar
siempre hay un pero aparece la verdad es
que nos empieza agarrar como el miedo y
la angustia hicimos ahí no será cosa que
además de venir a llevarme mate me
reemplazará del todo y se quedará
completamente con mi trabajo no
solamente con el trabajo aburrido sino
con el trabajo divertido también y aquí
surgen muchas cosas respecto de que
tenemos que estudiar cómo tenemos que
ser y de que tenemos que trabajar son
preguntas super válidas súper válidas
que la gente se hace que son las
investigaciones veo que se hace y que
seguramente muchos de ustedes se hagan
y parece entonces que con la tecnología
siempre estamos entre dos salas o el
mundo idílico utópico de sarah kane
alguno entenderá la referencia a otro no
o el mundo tremendo de sarah connor no
terminator está todo mal
hace poco en una investigación haciendo
investigaciones con mamás y chicos una
mamá nos decía hago sabes que mi hijo me
preguntó si cuando terminaba de rezar y
decía amén era como ponerse
u otro chico nos decía un adolescente
nos decía estoy re angustiado porque mis
viejos alquilaron una casa de fin de
semana y estoy voy a estar encerrado en
un campo sin wifi
encerrado en un campo sin wifi y
efectivamente él se sentía totalmente
totalmente lógico y esto que esperamos
de la tecnología esta rapidez está
customización la esperamos de cosas que
no tienen nada que ver con la tecnología
la esperamos de las relaciones la
esperamos de los trabajos las esperamos
de los intercambios e incluso en el área
que yo más conozco que tiene que ver con
el consumo la esperamos de los productos
que no tienen nada que ver con la
tecnología esperamos dientes más blancos
en menos tiempo y que el desodorante nos
dure más 94 horas 48 no y que la crema
en el pelo me funcione mientras estoy
dormida para optimizar las 24 horas que
tengo que son las mismas 24 que seguía
teniendo antes y eso se lo demandamos a
las marcas se lo demandamos a los
productos
y hace poco leí una frase que me pareció
espectacular y era yo tengo hijas
adolescentes así que la voy a utilizar
en cualquier momento más respeto que
cuando yo fui al colegio no existía
google
es buena es sano y los invito a que
reflexionemos cuando fue la última vez
que se quedaron con algo en la punta de
la lengua el nombre de un actor están
viendo una película no se lo acuerdan
alguien banco dos días sin acordarse o
lo familiar ya no soportamos no saber el
nombre de alguien no acordarnos no no
existe más casi esa sensación y por
supuesto también en otra investigación
un joven nos decía sabes que cuando yo
llego un lugar y el wifi me reconoce me
siento es como mi hogar si me siento que
me reconoció
dentro de poco vamos a tener
alfombrillas que digan hogares a donde
el wifi te reconoce o qué cosa peor que
te clava en el visto no porque no me
está contestando que pasó yo vengo de un
mundo primitivo y lejano no las cavernas
pero más o menos donde he mandado
postales he escrito cartas de papel y
mandado la carta por el correo qué pasó
con todo ese tiempo donde se nos fue
y la verdad es que cuando pensamos en
todas estas cosas no nos damos cuenta en
general de algo y es que en realidad los
humanos de naturales no tenemos nada o
en todo caso si hay algo que es natural
para nosotros es hacer tecnología es lo
que nos define como seres humanos
y además como no vivimos en un vacío
sino que vivimos en sociedad y vivimos
en una cultura esa ida y vuelta nos hace
nosotros lo hacemos pero eso también nos
hace a nosotros
y dónde está el botón del off alguna vez
lo preguntaron algunos lo encontró si lo
encontró sería bueno que comparte el
secreto porque es muy difícil de
encontrar y en un mundo tan acelerado
donde tantas cosas cambian que a veces
parece que no las podemos procesar no
tenemos esa capacidad hay algo que no
cambia y lo que no cambia es nuestra
necesidad de estar conectados
contactados como seres humanos yo
aprendí en investigación que lo que es
lujoso lo que más se valora es eso que
no abunda es eso de lo que hay poquito y
en un mundo tan sobre tecnificado lo que
no abunda es lo humano por eso hoy el
lujo es lo humano es esa conexión
emocional humana pero contacto es
contacto contacto es tomar un mate con
una amiga contactos son las divinas de
las mamás del grupo del colegio que te
avisan un domingo a la noche que el otro
día tienes que comprar mapa contacto es
hablar con un amigo por skype y hace mil
que no lo ves y te extraña y lo extrañas
hoy por hoy en nuestra sociedad en
nuestra cultura tecnificada porque somos
humanos y hacemos tecnología contacto es
contacto
y por eso los quiero invitar a que la
próxima vez que pensemos en los desafíos
que nos plantea la tecnología no nos
vayamos al mundo super idílico de estar
aquello de los singles o al mundo negro
y tenebroso de terminator sino que
pensemos hoy cada uno de nosotros en el
lugar en el que estamos cómo hacemos
para disfrutar cada vez más de este lujo
de lo humano o al menos cómo nos
transformamos en hamsters que son
capaces de vez en cuando de bajarse de
la ruedita muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]